hey
sit down did we take him no hey sit down
sit down or you're gonna class up
commander tickle commander
michael i'm zoe i'm a doctor i want you
to focus on slowing down your breathing
into
your nose out through your mouth
hi michael i'm marina bunnett the
commander of the ship
do you remember what happened on the pad
i'm a launch support engineer man
how long was i out we took off about 12
hours ago
please my sister she's alone we're not
going back what do you mean we're not
going back this is a two-year mission
two years is a long time to be away but
this is the opportunity of a lifetime
i can learn fast ready yeah i'm ready
we are taking the first steps to being
able to call mars
a second home
we're sorry that you missed the fellaini
but this is the next best thing
we think spaghetti i should warn you now
that zoe thinks she's the in-flight
entertainment
there's no easy way to say this
life support is damaged permanently
we only have enough oxygen board for
three people
everyone on board will suffocate before
we ever make it to mars
hey ava i gotta face the fact that i'm
not going to be there with you
this research is years of our lives are
we sure we want to throw it all away
[Music]
how much time do we have before it's too
late 20 days i think we should put
ourselves at risk
[Music]
for their sanity they need to try this
this is hopeless
[Music]
there's no way for all of us to survive
it's imperative that we try
[Music]
you